get ready for a ferocious box office
battle can those big cats Brad and Leo
take down the lion king well it won't be
easy but anything can happen once upon a
time in Hollywood
tell me about working with Leo your
chemistry in this film is magnetic you
know we come in same circle
I really admire his taste and his
choices and and I'm really happy this
one lined up for us with faces like
these who wouldn't throw down 16 bucks
that ticket to watch Brad and Leo on
screen for two hours at 41 minutes a lot
is riding on the success of this 90
million dollar film Brad twos 55 and 44
year-old Leo both recently addressed the
topic of aging out of Hollywood
Brad's quote it's a younger man's game
there's a shelf life on this thing
hopefully we have other things going for
us
there's no shelf life on you Brad Pitt
because you're on top of the roof fixing
the satellite TV and a little they
probably clean that one up I don't know
it's official old buddy has been a man a
has-been yeah that's something Leo
definitely is not in fact after a
four-year hiatus from the big screen
Leo has officially been called Hollywood
Flast movie star check this out the
Oscar winners got no agent they're the
ones that broker the deals he reportedly
took a five million dollar pay cut just
to make this movie but still got paid
fifteen million so not bad the Titanic
star also calls his own shots you may
have noticed Leo's never doing a
superhero movie a family film or a big
franchise
whoa the perpetual bachelor who loves a
good hoodie disguise casually hops on a
city bike to get around New York and can
often be spotted hanging with his 22
year old bottle girlfriend Camilla Moore
own he definitely knows how to keep the
mystery one report claims crew members
were told they were not allowed to make
eye contact with Leo on the once upon a
time in Hollywood set
Hollywood's changing in a lot of ways
this is kind of an art film I feel lucky
to been an actor that's been able to
work for this long and sure we know this
film is all about these two but Leo told
the Entertainment Weekly there's another
star who left him speechless
there was this immediate excitement and
seeing Luke Perry
you know on set it was incredible I I
remember being you know in my teens and
he was the manifestation of the new Dean
on television and everyone was great
about him and I act I felt this
overwhelming feeling of kind of being
starstruck but then he and I got to sit
down and talk about Los Angeles the 90s
his life where his career gone where my
career had gone where his life had done
with my and I could I was just so how do
I say this it really affected me when I
heard that news it was it was really
heartbreaking incredibly generous human
being
you
[Music]